mais oui mais c'est très bien et
d'ailleurs monsieur va ouvrir vre
ferme un se ESC reproducteur l'élevage
d'escagot est moins coûteux il n'exige
pas de produits vétérinaire c'est facile
c'est naturel c'est
bio
[Musique]
nous formons les éleveurs nous les
installons et puis nous rachetons pour
qu'on atteigne un niveau où l'escargot
est vraiment en VO sur le marché il faut
qu'on ait un côat au moins de 100000
éleveurs et nous sommes en train de
lutter petit à petit pour que nous
puissions vraiment atteindre ce niveau
[Musique]
làè comme ça
la bas d'escargot hydrate la peau elle
hydrate elle améliore te et elle
ralentit le vieillissement de la
[Musique]
peau